eugene france c'est dès le 12 avril sur
netflix et je vous lis netflix canal+
tout ça y est la place mantoue non non
kif et d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on a tourné sur ce plateau
on a tourné tu as eu la gentillesse de
nous accueillir syrie n'est d'ailleurs
je te remercie franchement tu aurais
c'est pareil je ne pense pas non mais on
a tourné une scène ici sur ce plateau
avec toi c'est une scène dans la série
où moi je veux pas je veux pas tout
dévoiler les amis sachez que baba joue
dans ma série un beau cadeau juste une
petite question que je mette les ce
n'est pas ce que je vais le découvrir
comme vous je n'ai pas dit un mot non
plus ne l'ait pas vu sexualité je vais
découvrir l'extrait gratter un mot il
faut que tu leur dis auprès de climax de
la série et les américains m'ont vu les
américains il ya un truc qui s'est passé
qui était très très drôle quand on a
tourné avec cet acteur et humoriste
américaine voilà non mais aux états unis
à un moment donné j'ai mis dans les
dialogues pour renouer avec mon fils je
vais le voir et je lui dis à mes yeux
d'anna mur fadeur je suis ton père
comment une baba jeudi baba parce que
j'ai me baba dans le sud est en fait les
américains ont écrit un dialogue il
devait dire ne m'appelle pas baba et ils
l'ont vraiment intégré il ya une
expression pour ça aujourd'hui
non le gars dit le jeune gadi doune baba
mai
[Applaudissements]
non
arrivé ça ou je te parle à hollywood
quand on veut éviter la familiale comme
on dit dans la longue balle à mai
et là alors c'est la vapeur c'est là
vous êtes à côté du monsieur à peu
laisser la personne à léogâne extrait
n'attendront pas longtemps
j'appuie comment vous pour voir l'excès
mais moi aussi mais maintenant tu vas
voir ton émission que dans la voie du
succès c'est technique c'est à dire que
tu va lancer un extrait dans lequel tu
es toi je suis moi dans ton émission
vient on reste dans l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]